president Trump threatens around with
fire and fury the long-awaited FISA
warrants application against Carter
pages released sort of and president
Trump's poll numbers still look solid
I'm Ben Shapiro this is the Ben Shapiro
show
oh boy do we have a lot to get to today
and we will get to all of it but first I
want to remind you that if you want the
best watches in the business for the
lowest possible price then you need to
shop with my friends over at
movementmovement' watches this company
has grown like crazy and now with almost
2 million watches sold in 160 plus
countries they continue to revolutionize
fashion on the belief that style should
not break the bank
I know movements great because I have
moved in sunglasses I have to movement
watches my wife has to movement watches
my parents have movement watches
everybody around the studio has movement
watches that is because they are clean
they're well-designed they don't break
they're just terrific go check them out
right now movement watches are all about
looking good and keeping it simple
they've expanded the sunglasses in
fashion for bracelets for her as well
and they don't just tell you how many
steps you've taken or blow your wrist up
with text messages the way that some of
these newfangled watches do instead they
tell you the time the way that it's
supposed to be told
movement watches start it's just 95
bucks at a department store you're
looking at four hundred five hundred
bucks
movement figured out that by selling
online it could cut out the middleman
and retail markup providing the best
possible price its classic design its
quality construction it's styled
minimalism again I have two of these
things and they are just terrific
get 15% off today with free shipping and
free returns by going to MVM t.com
shapiro that's MV MT comm slash appear
ocy movement keeps growing check out
their expanding collection go to mV mt
comm slash appear oh and join the
movement okay so today everyone is in a
sheer state of panic we're all going to
die well well it's true we will all
eventually die what everyone is
apparently very afraid of is that we are
going to get into nuclear exchange with
the Iranians who we were told by the way
don't have nuclear weapons why is
everyone so worried today well because
Iranian dictator Hassan rouhani who
really is just a stand-in for the
mullahs
he said over the weekend that if the
United States got into a shooting war
with the Iranians then it would be the
quote-unquote mother of all wars now
this is something that the Iranians have
been saying frequently since 1979 the
mother of all wars we're gonna take on
the great Satan and all the rest of it
well president Trump was in kind of a
bad mood over the weekend you can just
tell like from his Twitter feed you
could tell the news in a bad mood one of
the nice things about the president it's
so funny everybody is always doing this
sort of Kremlinology
on the administration Kremlinology is
what people used to do in the 1980s
1970s where you were trying to figure
out by the public statements
of the Russian administration the Soviet
Union you're trying to figure out what
it was they were thinking so it's all
this kind of puzzling out what exactly
are they doing behind the scenes with
President Trump ain't no Kremlinology
okay it's just what the guy says on
Twitter so president Trump goes on
Twitter and he tweets out this to
Iranian president rouhani and then this
is all in capitals all in capitals never
ever threaten the United States again or
you will suffer consequences the likes
of which view throughout history have
ever suffered before we are no longer a
country that will stand for your
demented words of violence and death be
cautious and it's all in capital letters
when the caps lock I invented caps lock
little did he know that it was going to
lead to a nuclear exchange this is
apparently the sort of DEFCON 2 of
Twitter if Twitter actually had a bold
or italics function then we'd presumably
in the middle be in the middle of the
nuclear exchange already now people on
the Left take this tweet and they say
well this means that the President of
the United States is going to start a
war with Iran he's going to go into Iran
to distract from his domestic scandals
hey first of all why would he possibly
want to distract from the fact that his
poll numbers are pretty good as we're
gonna get to in just one second but
second of all I think that we need to
take a little bit of a deep breath when
it comes to president Trump's tweeting I
have been saying this consistently for
more than two years that just because
the president tweets something doesn't
mean that it means anything I'm old
enough to remember when the President of
the United States said about North Korea
that there would be fire and fury and
fury and fire and fire fury fire fury I
remember that and it was oh my god we're
going to war with North Korea we're all
going to die and then there was a
missile alert a fake missile alert over
Hawaii and everybody said oh we're on
the brink of massive thermonuclear war
and then it turns out that President
Trump all he really wanted was to go to
South Korea and play golf with Kim
jong-un that's really all he wanted out
of the thing and then he came back and
he said the Kim Jong who had been
disarmed which he hadn't and then that
was pretty much the end of it we went
back to what we were doing before which
was waiting around the idea that Trump
is about to go to war with the Iranians
cuz the Iranians said something is so
ridiculous that it is beyond compare all
of the people out there who are doing
the panic attacks stuff oh were he's
he's got his finger on the nuclear
button we're all going to die he's been
in office for a year and a half we have
never been close to any sort of serious
military activity
we haven't and all of the talk about how
were five seconds away from the nukes
flying first of all I think that's an
implicit rebuke to the Obama
administration who which has said that
the Iranians are definitely trying to
moderate you remember Obama said this
they're definitely trying to moderate
they don't want nuclear weapons all they
want is nuclear power all they really
want is to be brought into the family of
Nations all we have to do is drop
billions of dollars in cash at their
front door on pallets and everything
will be hunky-dory well so much for that
idea it turns out that if you're gonna
talk about failed administration
policies with regard to Iran you might
want to start with the prior
administration not with the current
administration if you want to talk about
you know Trump's rhetoric you may want
to talk more about the fact that
President Obama hands in actual cash to
terrorists with the suggestion that this
was somehow going to turn them into a
bunch of moderates and now here they are
talking about the mother of all wars
okay so President Trump says all of this
and everybody goes nuts over all this
now is is all of this really good should
the president be tweeting all of this
stuff
I don't know makes much of a difference
except that American credibility when it
comes to military action is not at an
all-time high the presidents of the
United States he was the one who said
during the campaign you don't want to
Telegraph your intentions all the time
you sort of want to surprise people with
what you're gonna do you want to be
unpredictable well the president is
predictably unpredictable what that
means is when he says stuff like this he
can fairly guarantee there's no war
coming the president has the opposite
approach of Teddy Roosevelt Teddy
Roosevelt famously said that you have to
speak softly and carry a big stick for
President Trump it's tweet loudly and
then get together with some facetime and
Pat each other on the back so I think
the chances are much better that there
is some sort of summit in Dubai between
Trump and rouhani within the next year
and a half that any sort of serious
military activity happens between Iran
in the United States in the next year
and a half but it just goes to show you
the tenterhooks that Democrats are on
Democrats are so concerned everybody is
so concerned and here's the thing I
don't think that that's true I don't
even think that the Democrats are all
that concerned about this stuff I really
don't think the Democrats think that the
missiles are fly and that we're this far
away from nuclear war I think they are
just trying to promote a notion that we
are very close to some sort of
destabilizing event even though things
are relatively stable and here's the
thing the American people are not buying
this the American people aren't buying
this in any real way and the way you can
tell this is you can look at the
presidents poll approval number so
according to a brand-new Rasmussen poll
president Trump's approval numbers have
now climbed back to 46% which is near
the highest of his presidency all the
other polls have reflected that bump as
well the NBC Wall Street Journal poll
over the weekend showed Trump at an
all-time high of 45 percent now it is
important to note that 45% is not 50%
but it is also important to note that
the presidents of the United States won
his election when his approval rating
was about 40 to 43 percent so you don't
have to have really high approval
ratings in order to win a presidential
election and all of this despite the
fact that president Trump's moves with
Vladimir Putin last week in the Helsinki
conference were not wildly popular with
anybody except for Republicans the poll
showed 53% of Republicans approved of
Trump's behavior at his meeting with
Russian dictator Vladimir Putin which
isn't a good number among Republicans
only six percent of Democrats did but
none of that mattered much to the
overall approval for President Trump the
overall approval among Republicans for
president Trump currently stands at 88
percent that is the highest intra-party
approval ever polled ever polled
so among Republicans no president has
ever been more popular than president
Trump is right now and that has
something to do with President Truman
has a lot more to do with President
Trump's opponents as we'll talk about in
a little while so what exactly is
bolstering Trump's high approval rating
or at least decent approval rating right
now well the NBC Wall Street Journal
poll suggests that Trump is very very
reliant on the economy so 50 percent of
Americans like the way he is handling
the economy as opposed to only 36
percent of Americans who don't so all
the Democratic talk about how the
economy is going to collapse because of
the tax cuts around the verge of an
economic breakdown most Americans don't
believe that they believe the economy is
strong and President Trump is feeling
the effects of that 51 percent of
Americans disliked the way that Trump
has handled Putin overall 58 percent
disapprove of his immigration policy 53
percent approve of his tariff policy
what this adds up to is about 45% of
Americans overall approve of President
Trump which for president Trump is a
very good number 45 46 % and here's the
thing those poll numbers have really not
budged much for the President of the
United States in the last two-and-a-half
years Trump's approval rating has been
remarkably stable since long before he
was President of the United States
he began his presidency at about 44% he
is now at 45% after a year and a half
not a lot of volatility in those polls
news coverage simply doesn't touch
Trump it doesn't touch him because
pretty much everything is baked in when
people have an image of particular
people and they jump to that image
whenever they are in town so Republicans
have an image of President Trump as a
fighter who's willing to take on the
media and who's being wrongly maligned
by a bunch of people on the left and so
whenever anything bad happens to Trump
they jump right into that framework and
Democrats have a framework of Trump
where everything he's doing is
simultaneously buffoonish and evil it's
manipulative and clownish those are the
two things that Trump is according to
the left and so anything that Trump does
has to fall into one of those two
categories but the bottom line is that
Trump is basically the Super Bowl of
public opinion everybody has an opinion
about the Super Bowl everybody watches
the Super Bowl everybody watches the
commercial you're president Trump is the
center of the universe of the political
universe right now he's the thing
everybody is watching and everybody is
talking about and so that means that
everyone already has an opinion on him I
mean they're no undecideds when it comes
to President Trump you can't find one
seriously can you name anyone in your
own personal life who doesn't have an
opinion about President Trump of course
not and that means that his approval
ratings are going to be relatively
stable now is that good for Republicans
are bad for Republicans well it's good
for presidential elections it's good for
presidential elections because it means
that the presidential election won't
actually be a referendum on President
Trump it will be a referendum on the
income it will be in a referendum on who
the Democrats pick and this was for in
2016 if you look at 2016 the media got
it completely wrong about who the
referendum was about now I got the
election result wrong just like every
other pollster but what I did get right
as I said this was not going to be a
referendum on President Trump it was
going to be a referendum on Hillary
Clinton because Trump was very stable
but Hillary was bouncing around all over
the place the truth is that Trump his
election his election urine played a lot
more like an incumbent incumbent
president's usually win and the reason
they usually win when I say usually I
mean that only one president has ever
been defeated after one term without a
serious third party challenger since
1932 okay so it's been nearly a century
since somebody lost with without a
one-pot without a third-party challenger
the only exception being Jimmy Carter in
1980 the reason for that as incumbents
are well known we know them we have
opinions about them and that means that
we are really more thinking about what
the other guy be better than this person
would you take the devil you know over
the devil you don't
and some
President Trump that's how the 2016
election acted right people already were
saying okay we know who Trump is we just
don't know who Hillary is and people
eventually decided we don't like her
enough to elevate her above Trump in the
electoral college well the same thing is
going to happen in 2020 the same thing
is going to happen but there are other
ramifications as well talk about those
in just a second first let's talk about
how much money you're spending on stamps
okay the reality is then when you go to
the post office you're spending more
money than you are actually spending
just being the post office post office
is great but you spent the money on gas
to get there you spent the times you get
there there's no reason for you to do
any of that instead go to stamps com
there you can access all the amazing
services of the post office directly
from your desk 24/7 when it's convenient
for you you buy and print official US
postage for any letter any package using
your own computer and printer
the mail carrier picks it up you click
print mail and you're done
we'll use stamps calm here at the office
it ensures that our employees don't have
to run over the post office all the time
also they can automatically gauge how
much postage is going to cost you
printed out right on to the letter or
onto a piece of paper or onto a sticker
you stick it on the mail and you're
ready to go and right now when you use
Shapiro you get a special offer promo
code Shapiro it includes up to 55 bucks
of free postage plus a digital scale and
a four week trial don't wait though -
stamps calm and before you do anything
else click on the radio microphone at
the top of the homepage and type in
promo code Shapiro we use it at the
Shapiro household also a daily wire go
check it out right now stamps comm enter
that promo code Shapiro for that special
deal 55 bucks of free postage digital
scale four week trial it saves you time
it saves you money you get all the great
services of the post office without
actually having to go to the post office
so that stamps calm promo code Shapiro
okay so president Trump's approval
ratings continue to be fine no matter
what he does there is one area however
where his approval ratings do actually
tend to go so I think politics is sort
of like a balloon if you squeeze one
area of the balloon the pressure is
going to emerge in another area of the
balloon and right now the pressure with
regard to President Trump is tremendous
which means there's no air in that part
of the balloon my Trump has squeezed all
the air out of this part of the balloon
so where is all that air pressure going
it's going into the congressional races
so every time Trump does something that
is not great what happens is not that an
effects President Trump it actually
doesn't and instead effects
congressional elections and I'm saying
that because I don't think that it's
unique about Trump I think it's true for
virtually every president virtually
every president is baked in so George W
Bush was baked in which is why he won
re-election Barack Obama was baked in
which is why he won re-election well I
mean baked in I mean people already have
their opinions and those opinions on
remarkably stable about who the
president of the United States is that
means then when things go wrong it
doesn't actually reflect on the
President of the United States instead
it tends to reflect on the congressional
races and you can see that so in the
last month and a half
Trump's approval rating has basically
been the same or higher but the
Congressional generic ballot has changed
radically in favor of Democrats so at
the beginning of June Democrats led
Republicans in the generic ballot by
three percentage points now that number
is seven point four percent according to
Real Clear Politics so looking at
president Trump's approval numbers and
saying that he is successful or
unsuccessful based on those approval
numbers I think is a bit of a misdirect
you know President Obama also had
remarkably stable poll approval numbers
there were always around 50% they never
sank lower than about 47% and then
everyone hired about 53% right Obama's
ratings were stable but because the
presidency is not where we put our
energies because we are already invested
in the presidency our feelings tend to
come out in congressional races a lot
more so Barack Obama wins reelection
relatively easily over Mitt Romney and
he loses congressional seats in
virtually every election right he gets
blown out in 2010 Democrats have not
held the house since 2010 they proceeded
to lose the Senate they proceeded to
lose another 12 governorships they
proceeded to lose a bunch of state
houses in other words the presidency of
the United States is not the best
indicator of whether a president is
successful in his political agenda or
not I think that the polls that actually
matter and them and the results that
actually matter are some of those
congressional down ballot races now the
good news is Democrats are absolutely
blowing it on every front so if this
isn't a referendum about Trump and it is
a referendum on Democrats then perhaps
Democrats ought to get their act
together but they're not getting their
act together and here's the thing when
President Trump does something unpopular
when he does something that isn't good
it's not gonna reflect on on President
Trump it is gonna reflect on Congress
unless Democrats decide to make fools of
themselves so for example President
Trump does this meeting with Vladimir
Putin and it doesn't go particularly
well and I say it doesn't go
particularly well he said some things
that I think we're quite egregious there
are a lot of Republicans we
not supremely happy with president
Trump's performance with Vladimir Putin
last week in Helsinki one of those
Republicans was for example
representative trey gowdy republican
from south carolina he slammed President
Trump over his Russia equivocation this
is clip nine and here's what trey gowdy
had to say there was this equivocation
during the press conference that I'm
glad he corrected it but when you're the
leader of the free world every syllable
matters and you really shouldn't be
having to correct it when you're the
leader of the free world so this would
be an opening for Democrats right you
would assume that there are a bunch of
Republicans who aren't super happy with
what Trump did in Helsinki and so they
would be kind of warm to a democratic
message that said you know the president
really shouldn't have acted like that
but Democrats are so reactionary at this
point we are in the midst of a a
velocity increase in politics what I
mean by that is that when you when you
heat up a gas then one of the things
that happens when you heat up a solid
one of the things that happens the
reason that ice melts for example is
that the molecules start moving faster
it they bounce off of each other they
expand right this is what makes air
expand as you heat it up and that means
the velocity of the molecules is
increasing if I'm not screwing up my
basic physics okay that the same thing
is happening in politics as we have
increased the temperature in politics
everybody's ping-pong off with each
other harder and harder so instead of
people reacting with statesmanship and
some level of decency or or some level
of moderation to other people's
screw-ups instead we get people reacting
as wildly as possible which means that
again not screwing up my physics here
every action has an equal and opposite
reaction what that means is that if the
Democrats are ping-pong in off
Republicans incredibly hard Republicans
are going to recoil e in the exact
opposite direction so trey gowdy
criticizes the president in somewhat
measured tones and then Democrats lose
their minds and suggest that Trump is
actually in the pay of the Russian so
Susan Rice who you'll recall is the lady
who went on national television and lied
repeatedly about Benghazi she was the
lady who said that it was actually a
YouTube video responsible for a
terrorist attack that ended with the
murder of four Americans she lied to the
American people about Iran she lied to
the American people repeatedly she was
back on national television this time
suggesting that Trump was in the pay of
the Russians he's taken a series of
steps that had Vladimir Putin dictated
on
he couldn't have mirrored more
effectively what his motivations are I
think is a legitimate question one that
I trust that the special counsel is
investigating but the policies that this
president has pursued globally have
served Vladimir Putin's interests in
dividing the West undermining democracy
increasing fissures within NATO and has
done very little to advance us do you
really think that any Republican a
moderate is going to respond to that
sort of language and he's doing the
interests of Russia and that he's
there's something nefarious going on you
think that's really going to help
especially from the administration that
essentially did the bidding of Iran not
essentially did the bidding of Iran they
did the bidding of Iran okay that
administration the Obama administration
became the pr outlet for the Iranian
mullahs and here they are criticizing
Trump over this and suggesting that it's
because something deeply corrupt is
going Maxine Waters aunty Maxine the
beloved face of the New Democratic Party
and she goes around saying that Trump is
Putin's apprentice okay you think that
this is going to somehow cool down the
temperature and make me believe the
Democrats are reliable you got to be
kidding me I'm not surprised about this
president standing up for Putin as a
matter of fact I think he is Putin's
Apprentice
he's been under his tutelage for a long
time now and here is to get it done and
the American people are setting idly by
okay so Maxine Waters says that Trump is
basically like Mickey Mouse and The
Sorcerer's Apprentice and he puts on the
Wizards hat and then proceeds to break
up all the brooms but in any case if you
think that this is not gonna drive
Republicans more into the arms of
President Trump you're out of your mind
when Michelle wolf supposed comedian
alleged comedian when she suggests that
ice is like Isis you really think that
Republicans are going to respond the way
you think they are I really don't think
so hey here's a Michelle wolf doing just
that do you believe your way of life is
under attack
and are you ready to finally do
something about it
then apply now to join ice ices rooting
out the foreign enemy Isis terrorizing
the invaders Isis attacking when they
least expect Isis blowing up the status
quo
I'm Homeland Security Secretary Kerstin
Nielsen
it's popular nowadays to say Isis bad
but there's no better representation of
American values right now than Isis and
as an equal opportunity employer we
accept all levels of experience and
education from below to very low and
actively welcome those with diagnose and
then they create an iced flag that's
black and all these people wearing masks
so it looks like Isis right ice is get
it yeah that is definitely not going to
repel Republicans good job guys just
really well done Michelle wolf okay in
just a second I want to talk about the
the moderates in the Democratic Party
who are struggling and trying to figure
out exactly how to prevent their party
from being taken over by exactly the
sort of sentiment that leads to
Republicans retaining their majority
first I want to talk about your
underwear okay it is summer
that means it's so it's unbelievably hot
over the weekend it was one bajillion
degrees that is the technical term is
one bajillion degrees in Los Angeles and
that's why I was deeply deeply grateful
that I was wearing Tommy Chon underwear
Tommy John's like we've lightweight
breathable fabrics wedgie-proof designs
they keep you cool and comfortable all
summer long you don't get anymore that
swamp butts you're old cotton boxers
they don't stand a chance against the
summer heat and humidity but Tommy John
underwear is made with quick drying
moisture whipping wicking fabric it's
the best pair you will ever wear or it's
free that's their guarantee if Tommy
John isn't the most incredible fit
you've ever experienced it's on them no
questions asked so there's no reason for
you not to try Tommy John they're cool
cotton fabric tries four to five times
faster it keeps you 2 to 3 times cooler
then traditional cotton they don't just
make underwear by the way they make
other clothing as well and again they
have that latest in fabric technology
with patented wedgie-proof designs for a
fit so perfect it's almost like wearing
nothing at all that wedgie-proof design
would have been super useful to me back
in high school plus all Tommy trying
underwear is back by that guarantee that
best pair your level where it's or it's
free guarantee so stay cool and
collected all summer long with Tommy
John no adjustment needed hurry - Tommy
John calm / Shapiro's for 20% off your
first order that's 20% off your first
order at Tommy John
komm slash Shapiro for 20% off again
Tommy John comm slash Shapiro go check
it out right now so even Democrats are
beginning to realize that their
radicalism is wearing thin and this was
I think the funniest thing that happened
all weekend James Comey tweeted out a
plea to Democrats please don't move to
the left please
so James Comey the most self-serving FBI
director and former FBI director in
American history he to beat out
Democrats please please don't lose your
minds and rush to the socialist left
this president and his Republican Party
are counting on you to do exactly that
America's great metal wants sensible
balanced ethical leadership when Comey
runs four presidents on the Democratic
side in 2020 it's going to be lit as the
kids say but the the fact that that he
is actually saying something true here
is pretty amazing it's first time he
said something true in a while actually
but that's but that's pretty amazing
stuff people are beginning to realize
that the Democratic Russian left is
actually going to hurt them and so
Democrats have been struggling to push a
third way message so over the weekend
the Democrats held a big conference in
Columbus Ohio where they were attempting
to force back against the sort of
Alexandra Ocasio Cortez they're trying
forcing could be back against her wing
of the Democratic Party okay so here's
what the the Miami Herald and McClatchy
say leading moderate Democrats
forcefully argued this week that the
party can embrace the robust agenda of
change while still praising capitalism
and downplaying income inequality in
other words everything the empowered
liberal basis spends a year and a half
mobilizing against Democrats gathered
here in Ohio's capital city on Thursday
and Friday and what was an opening salvo
of the 2020 Democratic presidential
primary part of a conference organized
by the center-left think-tank Third Way
the longtime Washington face group was
unveiling the findings of a year-long
assessment launched after 2016 hoping to
convince potential presidential
contenders that they don't have to adopt
the hard left agenda and style of a
Bernie Sanders progressive included in
the report were a dozen big-picture
policy recommendations such as adopting
a robust apprenticeship program and
expanding unemployment insurance to help
workers find new jobs and encouragement
to bypass talk of income inequality for
an emphasis on creating opportunity this
is a giant fail no major Democrat showed
up for this thing zero okay because the
they are all afraid of the base and
let's be real about this politics has
become a referendum on coal
is not a referendum on actual policy
anymore and so there are too many people
in the Democratic Party who resonates to
the cultural critique posed by the
intersectional left by the Ocasio
Cortez's and Bernie Sanders's of the
party it's become a bumper sticker party
that is mainly focused not on its the
economy stupid or the Clintonian Third
Way instead it is heavily focused on
this virtue signaling I go to Whole
Foods and I put an anti-trump bumper
sticker on my car feeling that's why the
entire Democratic Party has been
hijacked by this radical left that has
better bumper stickers because let's
face it who had better bumper stickers
Bernie Sanders or Hillary Clinton no
question what's sexier talking about the
third way in which capitalism is good
but we need better unemployment
insurance or Alexandra Ocasio cortes
speaking truth to power about males in
the legislature here she is the new face
of the Democratic Party and those and
those crazy eyes I'm allowed to say
crazy eyes about her because the
Democrats said about Michelle Bachmann
so turnabout is fair play
here's Alexandria Ocasio Cortez I've
gotten her name right I think four
straight times on this show today so
good for me and here she is on Face the
Nation or eyes the nation is the case
maybe talking about the male legislators
that are hurting women Congress right
now is 80% male and that creates blind
spots in our legislation it means we
don't have family leave we don't have
paid maternal and parental leave it
means that we don't get the equal pay
that we want so I think those issues
certainly were important okay um if you
think that the reason that there aren't
enough giveaways is because males run
the government you're out of your mind
you're out of your mind it has nothing
to do with that it's not that men are
sitting around going you know what I
would really like my wife to be paid
less when she goes on maternity leave
right I would really like for women who
paid nothing when they go on maternity
leave it's just there are some of us who
believe that the market is not designed
to actually force businesses to pay for
people not to work but that's not what
companies do like I believe we have a
maternity leave policy at this company
I'm not sure but that is only because we
want to retain our employees not because
we think that it's actually great policy
to pay people not to work
hey but according to the center of the
Democratic Party it's all about evil
males and this makes certain people feel
good it makes you feel better to target
other people in politics than it does to
maybe acknowledge that there are forces
in the mark
that don't benefit you but it's gonna be
very difficult for Democrats to to
overturn this sort of cultural feeling
of the Democratic Party here's the proof
okay so there's a guy named Tim Ryan Tim
Ryan is a democratic representative from
Ohio he served in Congress since 2002 as
a rep from the 13th district which
covers Youngstown in the surrounding
area and he poses himself as sort of the
moderate Democratic responder to all of
these all of these radical Left Party
members but how is he priming and
apparently according to the intercept
he's planning on running for president
but how is he how exactly he's gonna run
for president is he going to run as a
Rust Belt Lou collar guy who's going to
bring opportunity back to Ohio through
unemployment insurance no he says that
he wants to run with the yoga vote not
kidding here's what he says he says
Ryan's district is according the
intercept is one of the few poor
majority white districts that is
represented by a Democrat but he won't
be running on a stereotypical
working-class persona instead he
believes his path to the White House
runs through the yoga vote this is a
downward facing tactic Ryan has long
been a champion of mindfulness
meditation and similar pursuits and has
even created a quiet time caucus in the
House of Representatives yeah that's
going well James Guinean publisher of
the mindful magazine who knows Ryan said
he isn't sure whether Ryan will run for
president but that the yoga vote has
gone mainstream in recent years the
so-called yoga voters are the kind of
folks who realize that while they grew
up with their mom say and pay attention
nobody trained them and how to pay
attention and use their mind to focus on
what's important that's a growing
population it's no loan it's no longer
just Lululemon yoga women he said anyone
who's negotiating the emotional landmine
of modern-day living could be someone
Ryan's message would resonate with yes
definitely this is going to cut against
the perception that Democrats are a
bunch of pansies who engage in yoga and
mindfulness meditation in their spare
time I can't imagine why they would
possibly lose I don't know like Michigan
Wisconsin Pennsylvania
remember Hillary Clinton said that those
30,000 deleted emails were all about
yoga okay so the yoga and then I'm Carly
but this is the thing the Democrat
whenever you have a party that appeals
to a particular base you have to think
who is sort of the person you're
appealing to when you make a TV show if
you're in Hollywood there's somebody
that the creator of the TV show has in
mind right who is the ideal
audience for this TV show so ESPN the
ideal audience is probably a minority
male okay because minority males tend to
watch more sports than non-minority
males so that is their target audience
the same thing is true with regard to
you know the hunting and fishing Network
if there is one that is targeting white
males disproportionately life time is
targeting a middle-aged woman who's
who's probably at home during the day
time to watch lifetime right then
everyone has the target audience so is
your target audience is the Democrats
really think their target audience is
gonna be women who go to yoga classes it
seems to me they already know that they
won those people what they actually need
the target is that blue-collar guy
living in Wisconsin Michigan in
Pennsylvania because if Hillary Clinton
had spent any time doing that she wins
the election but she didn't as the
Democrats are now going to double down
on this cultural gap between the yoga
folks and the pipefitters yeah real
bright real Brenna can't imagine why
they're losing election after election I
just can't imagine why that's happening
hey in just a second I want to talk
about the other big news of the weekend
which is this released FISA warrant
application regarding Karger page first
you're gonna have to go over to daily
wire.com and check it out for $9.99 a
month you can get the rest of this show
live and get the rest of the and reclaim
and show live there are some michael
knowles show live you can get to be part
of our mailbag when we have events and
we have two coming up in august if you
are a member then you get first crack at
the VIP tickets those are already sold
out in Dallas in Phoenix but we are
going to add new tour dates I think
sometime in the near future
so you don't want to go check that out
as well also when you subscribe you I
mean they're there all sorts of benefits
and we actually I think we launched the
Shapiro store today over at amazon.com
see finally after years and years and
years of promises I told you it would
happen I told you and you didn't trust
me but it did it eventually happened
unlike other politicians when I promise
something it happens eight years late
but go check it out over at amazon.com
right now wouldn't remember you also get
all sorts of other benefits that I can't
explain to you unless you get the annual
membership in which case here is a
benefit I can't explain to you do you
see this right here before your very
eyes this this leftist tears hot or cold
tumbler do you see the magic of it can
it can you feel it through your screen
can you hear it in your ears resonating
well that reverberation is the holiness
of this Grail go check it out
the leftist tears hierarchal tumbler
with the annual subscription $99 you're
cheaper than the monthly and please
subscribe at youtube and itunes that
means that you get access to our Sundays
specials yesterday's
was Eric Weinstein I think it was one of
our best ever it's really great go check
it out we are the largest
fastest-growing conservative podcast in
the nation
[Music]
all righty so let's talk a little bit
about the release of this FISA warrant
application against former Trump foreign
policy adviser Carter Paige so over the
weekend the DOJ the FBI they released
via a FOIA request a Freedom of
Information Act requests from Judicial
Watch then released the application for
the FISA warrant against Carter page now
if you haven't been following the Muller
investigation and all the collusion
stuff for a long time
quick reminder Carter page was a foreign
policy adviser for President Trump the
FBI and the Intel community thought the
Carter page was actually acting as a
go-between for the for maybe maybe the
Trump campaign and the Russians at the
very least they thought that he was
working with the Russians to do their
work as some sort of foreign better
basically that he was an advisor to the
Kremlin and they were paying him that
was the suspicion of the of the foreign
policy intelligentsia of the of the
intelligence community and that had been
their opinion since 2012-2013 well they
took out a warrant application against
Carter page in October 2016 the
suggestion by some on the right is that
the reason that they went after Carter
pages because Carter page was attached
to the Trump campaign and because they
were attempting to drum up some sort of
evidence against Trump in advance of the
election I've always been more than
slightly skeptical of this particular
allegation simply because it turns out
that the Russia investigation according
to Devon Nunez not according to me
occurring to Devon Nunez at a House
Intelligence Committee was launched on
the back of the George papadopolis
investigation that was another low-level
adviser to the Trump campaign who
supposedly was meeting with a London
professor who actually was a Kremlin
cutout and then was trying to coordinate
with the Trump campaign write that in
Papadopoulos has pled guilty to like the
FBI and he'll spend a little bit of time
in jail so everyone is focused in on
this FISA warrant application because
the suggestion is that this is good
evidence the intelligence community was
trying to get Trump well over the
weekend they released a very very
redacted version of this Kyra Paige FISA
warrant the argument is that the Carter
page FISA warrant was basically gotten
on the back of the so-called steel
dossier you'll recall that the steel
dossier was a dossier compiled by
Hillary Clinton and the firm fusion GPS
it was an apple research file and then
eventually was supplied to the FBI and
that was used to go after Kyra Paige so
this is a way to sort of officialize to
to create a an official government
record of all the stuff that trumpet
supposedly done via this democratic paid
for steel dossier suggestion by
republicans was that all of this was
trumped up in order make Trump look bad
now the information was not released
before the election I wouldn't actually
see any of this stuff before the
election however the suggestion is that
the intelligence operatives were
politicized in some way now is there
some credibility to the idea the
intelligence operatives were politicized
in some way well sure Lisa page Peter
struck write top members of the FBI were
in fact anti Trump is it possible that
they went above and beyond the call of
duty toward personal bias in targeting
people like Carter page that's certainly
possible but we don't know that from
this application so you're gonna hear a
lot today on the radio and and in the
media from from people on the right that
this FISA warrant application is clear
evidence that the FBI was attempting to
target Trump members of the campaign in
order to get Trump that's not really
what this application shows maybe the
application will show that one get the
whole thing but what this application
really shows is a few things so let's go
through it first of all it does show
that the FBI relied heavily on the
so-called steel dossier in taking out
this application for surveillance
warrants against Carter page the dossier
was compiled by Christopher Steele as
you recall at the behest of Hillary
Clinton and fusion GPS it was allegedly
handed over to the FBI in September 2016
then served as a key component of the
FISA warrant application it played a
major role okay was not a minor role it
was the key component with that said
most of the steel dossier had to do with
Trump and Paul Manafort and none of that
stuff made it into this warrant
application but it didn't but but the
part about Carter Page did which
suggests that the FBI took it seriously
we don't know how much of the steel
dossier was corroborated so what you're
hearing from a lot of folks on the right
is that the entire steel dossier was
absolute tripe and that none of it was
corroborated we don't know the answer to
that we know certain parts have
obviously not been corroborated the most
inflammatory parts about Trump being
peed on by Russian and all that
none of that's been corroborated but we
don't know what's been corroborated
because all of the corroborating
evidence was redacted in this FISA
warrant application and they're just
pages and pages of blacked out material
so we don't actually know what the FBI
was doing there okay one thing we do
know is that when when Devon Nunez
suggested that the application didn't
warn the FISA Court that this was based
on an Apple research file from Hillary
Clinton
I don't think that's true I don't think
that's true because here is what it
actually said in the FISA warrant
application quote a us-based law firm it
hired the identified US person to
conduct research regarding candidate
ones ties to Russia it's pretty obvious
what they are saying is that a US based
law firm this would be fusion gps had
hired the identified US person that
would be Christopher Steele to conduct
research regarding candidate ones ties
to Russia that'd be Trump the identified
US person hired source one to conduct
this research that would actually be
Christopher's steel the identified US
person to conduct research was fusion
gps the us-based law firm was perkins
coie the identified US person never
advised source one as to the motivation
behind the research into candidate ones
ties to Russia
the FBM is the key sentence the FBI
speculates that the identified US person
was likely looking for information that
could be used to discredit candidate
ones campaign so it says clearly in the
application that this was an apple
research file and so the talk about
though it was big why the intelligence
community lied in order to get the
application through I don't see the
evidence of that the FBI said did
suspect Carter page being a Russian
agent here's the part where it starts to
get dicey the FBI the intelligence
community they've been all over Carter
page since 2012 has he been prosecuted
they surveilled him have they come up
with anything we've seen no evidence
that they did now does that mean that
the original investigation was bad no I
mean the police and the detectives they
investigate stuff all the time the FBI
investigates stuff all the time it
doesn't pan out but the fact they were
never able to get anything on Carter
page suggests that maybe this was a case
of overzealousness a final myth that has
to be put to bed the FBI warrant
application here did not use a Yahoo
News file in order to go after in order
to go after Carter page they used the
Yahoo News story that was leaked by
Christopher Steele not in order to
corroborate Christopher Steele's story
but in order to talk about what exactly
Carter pages response to the actual
dossier was so that's what you need to
know the answer really is that we don't
know enough to to suggest whether this
FISA warrant was was real or not we just
don't know enough at this point you can
see that this has broken out into a
conversation between Republicans over
over all of this House Republicans asked
for these redactions to be removed the
truth is the President of the United
States ought to simply remove all
redactions and release the file now
that's what really ought to happen here
okay meanwhile
and this is I think a bit ridiculous so
there are some reports over the weekend
that President Trump had engaged in
womanizing behavior over the course of
his life
why anyone be shocked by this is beyond
me of course the president said that we
all know that already that is not any
shock at all however Robert Jeffress who
is a a pastor he came out and he then
threw Ronald Reagan under the bus
suggesting that if you're worried about
donald trump's womanizing perhaps you
should be worried about Ronald Reagan's
womanizing back in 1980 evangelicals
chose to support twice married Hollywood
actor who was a known womanizer in
Hollywood his name was Ronald Reagan
they chose to support him over Jimmy
Carter a born-again back to a Sunday
school teacher who had been married
faithfully to one woman the reason we
supported President Trump over President
Reagan was not because we supported the
womanizing or a divorce
we supported his policies okay so this
is a stretch okay to compare Ronald
Reagan to Donald Trump is is rather
insane the fact is that Ronald Reagan
was divorced by Jane Wyman not the other
way around and then he was shortly
thereafter married to Nancy Reagan so
the idea that he was you know a
womanizer in the same league as
President Trump is a slander on
President Reagan and unnecessary in the
first place to go after Reagan in order
to protect Trump seems unnecessary in
the first place meanwhile the President
of the United States is targeting
amazon.com again so he is going after
amazon.com this is one of his favorite
things to do again I don't know why the
president is really all that concerned
right now like really he seems he seems
worried about a lot of things and I'm
not saying why he's so worried right now
I mean to be frank with you there's no
bad situation on the horizon there's
nothing terrible happening right now and
if you were not on Twitter everybody
would have a certain sense of stability
that they lack right now but he's weeded
out this morning the Amazon Washington
Post has gone crazy against me ever
since they lost the internet tax case in
the US Supreme Court two months ago the
next step is the US Post Office which
they use at a fraction of real cost as
their delivery boy for a big percentage
of their packages in my opinion the
Washington Post is nothing more than an
expensive lobbyists for Amazon it is it
used as protection against antitrust
claims which many feels should be
brought and the President of the United
States should not be going
for amazon.com this way first of all
amazon.com okay you want to call me a
lackey for Amazon fine do it
okay Amazon is the best company in
America Amazon makes everybody's life
better Amazon is awesome Amazon is a
fantastic company they allow you to get
anything you want at any time and the
idea that they're somehow operating off
the back of the Postal Service is just
ridiculous first Amazon does pay state
taxes in 45 states plus the District of
Columbia the law does not require
companies without a physical Nexus in a
state to pay taxes in that state Amazon
does anyway they also pay property taxes
on their facilities in all of these
states also when Trump talks about the
post office this is it I don't
understand why you would think that
Amazon is hurting the post office Amazon
may be the only company in America
keeping the US Postal Service afloat
most companies now ship via FedEx and
eventually Amazon will stop using the US
Post Office at which point the u.s. post
office will simply go bankrupt
finally Trump may be right about Amazon
competing other businesses out of the
market but this idea that the Washington
Post is a lobbying outfit for Amazon is
absurd the Washington Post was the anti
Republican going back decades the I just
don't understand the here's it here's
what I think I think the president ought
to calm down he ought to calm down the
reason you got to calm down is because
right now the biggest obstacle to
president Trump's success is president
from giving a feeling a strong feeling
of chaos there is no chaos going on
there may be chaos inside the
administration but there is no serious
chaos going on in the United States
right now the economy is solid we're not
in the middle of any foreign crisis
everything is basically okay the biggest
obstacle to Trump success is this
feeling that everything is variable that
everything is volatile that everything
is changing at all times but things
aren't actually changing all that much
it's incredibly tiring and there's no
reason for us to be tired
there's no reason when things are this
good the level of panic in the country
should not be this high and President
Trump is contributing to that with these
tweets the president has done a fairly
good job of governing the stuff he says
and the stuff he does are two very
different things when it comes to policy
the president's policy has been overall
quite conservative and the results can
be seen in the strength of the United
States right now if we could just
dispense with the feeling of chaos I
think everybody honestly I think need
Walt's re-election I think Republicans
would be in much better shape than the
Congress I really think it's almost it's
almost that simple okay time for a thing
I like and then we'll do a couple of
things that I hate so thing I like we're
gonna do some jazz this week the reason
were gonna do some jazz this week is
because I'm annoyed and one of the
reasons that I'm annoyed is because
there's this whole hubbub last week and
which a bunch of people on the Left
suggested that I was a racist why do
they suggest that I was a racist well
they couldn't actually come up with any
evidence that I was a racist the reason
I was a racist was supposedly because I
don't like rap guilty guilty
I hate rap I think rap is garbaggio I've
thought rap is garbaggio since I was a
small child because it sounds to me like
rhythm and talking with no actual melody
or harmony the small elements of melody
and harmony that exist do not make up
for the the actual bulk of rap which is
somebody speaking rhythmically to a beat
okay that is well that's what
distinguishes rap from other forms of
music I've said I don't think it's a
form of music and this got me and all
sort so people say how dare Shapiro not
like rap if you don't like rap means you
don't like black people which is really
weird because there are a lot of people
who don't like classical music I
wouldn't suggest they don't like white
people and said what a weird argument or
if you don't like mariachi music do you
not like Latino people like what what is
this nonsense you don't like klezmer do
you hate Jews like what what what did
what also if I don't like black people
why do I like jazz so much so it's time
to do some jazz this week and this is
not an attempt to prove I'm not racist I
don't have to prove anything to you
people I'm not a racist it is to prove
that there is an actual great form of
black music right jazz was historically
a black art form and it's actually
awesome okay like you want to listen to
some good music made by black folks
don't listen to some of the crappy rap
that's out there that humanizes women
and treats drugs is something good
instead what you listen to some awesome
classical jazz okay so here is the Oscar
Peterson trio love the Oscar Peterson
trio this is a cut called blues etude
from the Oscar Peterson trio and it's
just awesome stuff
[Music]
Magne play
his left hand here is ridiculous so my
dad is like is a is a jazz pianist is
actually really terrific my dad as a
jazz pianist you can go find a couple of
cuts of him on YouTube we have a couple
of cuts that we put up that are they're
really great but Oscar Peterson is just
fantastic if you if you want more kind
of user-friendly jazz from Oscar Peters
and go listen to his West Side Story
album which is really terrific so go
check that out
ok time for a couple of things that I
hate already so a bunch of people from
the movie fantastic beast got up at
comic-con and started lecturing about
how it's time to impeach Trump because
that's just what I need to hear what I
need to hear is zoe kravitz who plays
lettle estranged say that she would
impeach Trump and apparently they came
up with their own impeachment spell I am
not kidding it was impeach yes Maximus
ok number one read another book read
another book ok the reason that
everybody was doing this was apparently
Johnny Depp who appears as grinned wold
in the movie made a surprise appearance
after the panel in full makeup and
character as Greenwald and delivered a
fascist speech that borrowed from
President Trump because of course Trump
is a fascist with a magical supremacy
twist he said we who live for freedom or
truth the moment has come to rise up and
take our rightful place in the world and
then the star of the film Eddie Redmayne
who plays the Maja's huala gist Newt
Scamander charged with hunting and
eventually taken down Greenwald even
suggest in a post panel interview the
movie will draw inevitable comparisons
between the rise of a fascist wizard and
the current political landscape said I'm
enlisted by Dumbledore to try and track
him down and capture him what's happened
is Grindelwald belief that purebloods
should reign over the non magical beings
it's a political thing he's rallying
more and more people and it causes
divisions across families he's pretty
hypnotic it's all about Trump is by
Emily Zanotti over at Daily wire ok if
you wonder why people on the right are
annoyed by the folks in the culture who
insist on inserting themselves into
politics and then suggest that they're
not actually political they're just
speaking out on behalf of human rights
well this is why if you've decided to
make a metaphor about how President
Trump is actually Hitlerian
and then you create a spell called
impious Maximus and you go in from the
comic-con and you brag about it we're
gonna make fun of you we're going to
it's just it's just the thing that's
going to happen it's really
ie okay and then here's as I've said
before the left wants to claim the
commanding heights in the culture the
right wants to claim the commanding
heights in politics and both of them are
getting their wish okay other things
that I hate so apparently people are
counting Elizabeth Warren as the as the
next kind of great hope for the
Democratic Party and there's an article
in New York magazine with a picture of
her fist at the top I mean she's looking
pretty gaunt there and the whole idea
here is that Elizabeth Warren is the new
populist leftist that she's going to
make all of this happen and she is she's
going to run for president
hey that's exactly what you need that's
really what you need you don't need
Elizabeth Warren you know sort of
moderate as she was back when I was at
Harvard Law School she was sort of a
moderate Democrat back when I was at
Harvard Law School what you actually
need is Elizabeth Warren the radical
leftist the who will be how old how old
is she right now I'm gonna look at Emma
with the son but Elizabeth Warren is
currently 69 years old so what you
actually need
they ran last time a what seventy year
old woman how old was it held was
Hillary Clinton in the last election
cycle I believe she was 70 years old or
approaching seven years old I think she
was 69 right she was 69 years old she is
68 years old well we actually knew next
time is we need a 72 year old woman who
sounds a lot like Hillary Clinton and
acts a lot like Hillary Clinton and is
just about as sincere as Hillary Clinton
but also things she's a Native American
that's what we need
yeah that's definitely gonna be Trump go
for it guys just enjoy ourselves go
full-scale Elizabeth Warren let's see
how that goes for you okay now let's do
a quick Federalist paper so we are all
the way up to Federalist 38 moving
steadily through those Federalist Papers
every week we do one so you have a
little bit more knowledge about the
foundations of the country and the
background of the Constitution's
Federalist 38 is by James Madison the
so-called father of the Constitution and
he writes about the difficulty of coming
together regarding a constitution and
then he says that critics of the
Constitution aren't being consistent in
their critiques he explains that if you
were looking for doctors to diagnose you
with an illness and then act upon it and
they created a diagnosis and then a
bunch of new doctors came and they said
no no that diagnosis is all wrong but
they offered no actual diagnosis that
you might say well okay so what's your
diagnosis
this is his complaint that all the
people who are criticizing the proposed
Constitution have come up with no
serious workable alternatives he says it
is a matter of both wonder and regret
that those who raise so many objections
against the new Constitution should
never call to
the defects of that which it is to be
exchanged for it is not necessary that
the perfect that the former should be
perfect it is sufficient that the latter
is more imperfect in other words the
Articles of Confederation are worse than
the Constitution so we should have at
the Constitution and then he says you
can't say that the functions of the
government are necessary and then not
give them the power to enact it now
I actually find this Federalist paper a
little bit unfair if you read the
anti-federalists paper there's some very
the anti-federalist papers were put
together by people who are on the other
side of the Constitution and a lot of
their critiques are really solid and
really well taken a lot of them talked
about the possible growth of the federal
government the idea that the government
was being given too much centralized
power and a lot of those things have
come true today now it is important to
remember the historical context the
historical context is that no one
thought that the federal government
would grown this way no one in America
would be what the federal government
currently is it was unthinkable at the
time so in that way Madison Hamilton
John Jay the founders of the creators of
the Federalist Papers they were right
about the fact that the Constitution was
better than the Articles because they
never could have conceived that the
Constitution would eventually grow to
encompass nearly all of American life
but the anti-federalists were right in
that they saw that where the slippery
slope was going to go and I think it's
important to read both the Federalist
Papers and the anti-federalists papers
maybe when we're done going through the
Federalist Papers after another 50 weeks
maybe we'll start going through the
anti-federalists paper so you can see
the responses to the Constitution at the
time I always better to know more than
you did yesterday that's we tried to do
here so we'll be back here tomorrow with
all the latest i'm ben shapiro this is
the ben shapiro show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Sonia Villarreal executive producer
Jeremy boring senior producer Jonathan
hey our supervising producer is Mathis
Glover and our technical producer is
Austin Stevens edited by Alex and Garo
audio is mixed by Mike Carmina hair and
makeup is by Jess wha of era the Ben
Shapiro show is a daily wire for word
publishing production copyright Ford
publishing 2018